yeah so uh ever since ever since then
ever since then me and sunny have been
cooking almost like every day so we used
to like uber eats almost every day and a
big a big thing a big deal is because we
do have a dishwasher now so uh we don't
have to wash dishes ourselves anymore
and that takes so much of the effort out
in the cooking process because right you
know i like i find i find like i find
cooking relaxing you know i actually
find it relaxing to chop up the onions
or chop up the vegetables or whatever
prepare the dish cook the dish it's the
it's the clearing up that is always put
me off cooking all right ever since i've
gotten the dishwasher cooking has
actually been an enjoyable experience
for me yeah i feel the more i'm doing it
now like i used to [ __ ] dread it like
i it was just like stressful even like
following the menu or the the recipe
somehow i [ __ ] it up in some regard i
don't know i was like i'm following the
recipe how how does this taste like [ __ ]
yeah and but like now the more i'm like
slowly sounds like hell bucky cook and
like you know trying out like really
easy like pastas and like you know
something that is very difficult to [ __ ]
up kind of thing i'm like oh
wow
it's kind of fun
the [ __ ]
is this what is this what it feels like
to be like good at something yeah and
it's just like when you when you see
people eating your meal and they're just
enjoying it and feeling happy i'm like
oh this is how chefs feel oh my god oh
my god i think i think i found like a
new hobby or something it's uh genuinely
like a good feeling to cook something
that you're proud of and people also
enjoy your cooking i get it now mom i
get it okay i get what i am i get why
you was always like eagle eyed on me
whenever i like eat any of your meals
okay i get it now i like cooking it's
just a lot of work but also
um i i'm also really bad with portion
control
right when i make food i make food like
a lot like a feast yeah
i used to make a lot of lasagna from
walls is that i would then eat lasagna
you make a little lasagna anymore yeah
yeah but is it world famous
i totally forgot to make the white sauce
layer right and i was like why does this
taste like bricks
because there was like no like white
layers to balance out the tomatoes yeah
but yeah so i i would have make lasagna
i always liked leftover lasagna more
than lasagna
really something about lasagna sometimes
that like the next day when you when you
heat it up it's like perfect yeah it's
because it's so thick right yeah it's so
thick it kind of gets i don't know try
it it's like i i have tried it it's like
it's like how leftover deep dish pizza
tastes better than the fresh sometimes
yeah sometimes i don't know why but at
least at least the lasagna that i made i
don't know maybe it was like something
are you talking about microwaved lasagna
or do you just eat it straight out of
the [ __ ] fridge
uh i don't know like properly made
lasagna and then i would like put it
back in the next day yeah i'll put it
back in the oven yeah yeah oh okay
it's good yeah i think maybe it's
because like the the the juices like
coagulate yeah like solid it like seeps
in right like you could like cut through
it like a cake
whereas lasagna that goes [ __ ]
everywhere i think i'm wrong i generally
prefer normal lasagna there's something
about when i used to make it that for
some reason i liked it the day after
more now i get that i don't know why
look at that it's like hurry right like
that curry the day after tastes just as
good as absolutely
no i've heard that that's like the
biggest fallacy i've ever heard because
i've had i've had day old curry it
definitely doesn't taste as good as like
what kind of curry though indian curry
right right right because i understand
why okay indian curry may not be the
same because in with japanese curry it's
definitely better the day after yeah
because it's it's taken the time for
like everything to like
sarah are you uh sorry okay hong kong
but i i was saying japanese curry tastes
the same no matter what i feel
yeah i i feel like i've never had bad
curry but i've never had curry that's
like made me like [ __ ] amazed about
how good it is it is the most like six
out of ten cards there's some like
gourmet ones where they use like really
rich stock and they have like really
like uh good quality beef bites yeah at
the end of the day it's still generally
it's still japanese yeah exactly um with
pizza
i do do you like i was wondering about
this because you know there's people who
are like purists that like stone baked
uh uh what's uh where was it from uh
napoli napoli napoli like that's the
only style that's the correct style
which type of pizza is your favorite
style i was just curious
yeah i do like stone-based stone bait is
the only pizza where i can eat the crust
okay because okay because like some like
sourdough stone bay pizza oh my god okay
yeah it's i'm a crust i'm a cross hater
but i'm gonna eat that [ __ ] crust i'm
gonna enjoy it okay american pizza is
the best pizza i think like what like
what kind of american pizza like a new
york pizza that's like the best to be
fair new york pizza is pretty [ __ ]
bomb they i think american style of
making pizza is the best way i uh i love
stone baked i love stone bake right i
love it don't get me wrong but like
there i don't know what it is about
americans italians italians i i hear you
italians like i thought
a whole generation let's just just like
die
again here's my argument right the thing
with the thing with stone baked pizza
that sometimes kind of pisses me off
why are they so goddamn light with the
toppings like they put like one
pepperoni on it and call it a day you
know which i get it you don't you don't
want to like submerge it but also
everything falls off like immediately as
well i think it's like nothing stays in
place
isn't that based off like
isn't that based off like the it's
either napoli or the other type of uh
italian pizza but like it's not supposed
to be a heavy meal yeah it's supposed to
be very very lovely i don't know which
one it is yeah i love the heaviness of
american pizza right right like it's
like a it's all like a nice by american
pizza what do you mean because there's
so many different types well the
american style of making pizza is like
the
from what i understand like new york
it's like like dominance yeah it's like
perfectly constructed right
where it's like this it's this slice
that like is very solid on its own like
when it's cut up nothing like falls off
nothing like [ __ ] slips off or
anything it's a nice solid bit of pizza
i love it also one thing i tried which i
thought was going to be disgusting all
right this is this is vile i know it
sounds gross hear me out right
i had this do you like the grease do you
like the grease yes so
oh
i tried the hot dog in the crust pizza
and i [ __ ] loved it hot oh oh like a
like a hot dog in the crust i [ __ ] i
really enjoyed it do you like cheesy
crust
yes but i like the hot dog one more
really
what about an extra meal but what if you
put the cheese inside of the hot dog and
then you put that in the crust oh that's
that's that's just not even a crust
anymore like whenever whenever whenever
people whenever people say oh but do you
eat stuffed crust stuffed brush is good
stuffed crust is what you eat when
you're like when you don't want to
actually eat crust okay it's a
mozzarella stick okay and that's this is
just a [ __ ] hot dog okay you you're
eating
i like the hot dog you get it in japan
oh really yeah uh pizza hut do it oh
you're not going to pretend that this is
better than stone baked pizza or like
honestly fresh [ __ ] pizza okay but
okay but in japan no way
no [ __ ] way am i listening to this
right now in japan
there's in japan okay there's two types
of pizza in japan right yeah there's
pizza and then there's pizza yeah all
right two different things no i'm not
you guys love but it is
we got like an hour left on this
recording can we order a pizza hut pizza
with sausage in the crowd i actually
want to try it i'm just saying we should
do it we should all have a live reaction
yeah why why because i want to see your
reaction i want to see your hot dog
crust pizza it's a hot dog crust pizza
camera have you had one i've never tried
it yeah i want to see what have you
never tried it because i barely eat
cheesy crust i just want like a regular
crust i'm pretty sure they have it man
i'm telling you why do you like cheesy
crust it's too heavy
and you want a hot dog crust no honestly
it's like it's so good it's like a very
tight hot dog it's like
it's like wrapped around it's like a
bite-sized hot dog it's like a hot dog
burrito bro it's
so in japan right there's there's two
types of pizza there's pizza which is
like stuff like pizza hut domino's
american pizza basically right and then
there's pizza which is the italian pizza
yeah right so like when if you ever go
to like a an italian like restaurant or
whatever or establishment
you'll be able to know the difference
between like the italian like stone
baked stuff that god likes and then the
american stuff that connor likes
so at least gusting at least japan has
like made a distinction being like you
know at least they're not one of those
countries that are like all pizza is the
same like i remember when i first went
to new york right and i had my first
like new york pizza and the selling
point of this pizza uh was that you
could literally tilt your face you could
literally tilt the pizza and you could
see the oil dripping off it and i'm just
like how is this a selling point you're
meant to make this appetizing to me this
is just pure fat that's like rolling off
now
but i went to a place in new york that
was like i guess like kind of famous in
new york i forgot what it was but like
it's they're famous for like dabbing the
oil off of pizza off the pizza so it's a
really really it's it's a massive pizza
but it's really thin and really light
yeah so like i don't know about like the
full or like oil dripping off thing like
if that was not a good point
but like the point is you're still
dabbing off the oil because there is so
much oil on the pizza right right and to
me that's that's not that's not
appetizing i don't know like when i see
that much oil on anything that just i
don't want to eat it you know i i can i
can feel i can feel my arteries just
clogging me look as much as like you
know there's a place called pizza slice
in shibuya that's really good that does
uh new york style pizza [ __ ] bomb i
can only go there maybe like once a
month though because my god after two
slices i am like about to explore look
look i i get it where you know i i get
that it's a nice fast meal it feels good
it feels unhealthy but to say that it is
better than stone baked pizza
that's where i draw the lion man no
[ __ ] way if i had to choose oh god so
hard i just i just like pizza in general
yeah that's fine it's all delicious
i'm not saying that stone bait not
delicious it is excellent i'm not i'm
not saying that new york pizza is not
delicious as well in its own way because
like both types of pizza have their
benefits because because like the only
thing can be an everyday meal the the
only pizza that i'd say the americans do
the best is chicago pizza she can't do
stuff
but like that's like that's not even
that's not even nowhere else even does
it that's not a pizza that's a pie no no
yeah exactly it's it's not a pizza it's
a pizza lasagna but it's a pizza lasagna
that's what that's what chicago deep
dish pizza is and that's why it's
[ __ ] amazing